Der FC führt weiter die Tabelle an, der HSV und Kaiserslautern sind ihm aber dicht auf den Fersen. Die zweite Bundesliga, der Männer, sie hält uns weiterhin auf Trab und darüber spreche ich jetzt mit Nils Baumhoff von den Rocket Beans und Sebastian Zovell vom SWR. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Langeheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rossi ist zu kurz ab, wäre lang genug für Gilly Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1-0.
Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Ja Leute, was soll ich sagen? Ich muss mich hier schon wieder entschuldigen. Solltet ihr letzte Woche alle den Podcatcher eures Vertrauens wie wild aktualisiert haben und keine neue Ligaturfolge zur zweiten Liga gefunden haben, dann war das kein Fehler bei euch, sondern ja eine Abfolge unglücklicher Ereignisse, was auch dazu führt, dass ich hier jetzt sitze und nicht mag. Ich bin Eva-Lotta Bohle und ich habe trotz mehr Personaldrama in den letzten sieben Tagen als bei Kaiserslautern und dem ASV zusammen die Ehre, heute über die zweite Bundesliga der Männer zu sprechen. Und bevor ich euch die beiden Menschen vorstelle, die das gleich mit mir machen, wie immer der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch Euro-Spenden, also werdet gerne Rasenfunk-Supporter innen, falls ihr das noch nicht seid. Den Link dafür findet ihr auch in den Show-Notes. Jetzt darf ich euch aber die beiden Gäste vorstellen und wir fangen an zum, ich glaube es ist eine Rasenfunk-Premiere, korrigiere mich, wenn ich da falsch liege, aber du bist sicherlich schon vielen bekannt, vor allem wenn sie Bundesliga hören. Hallo Nils, schön, dass du beim Rasenfunk dabei bist.
Hallo, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Ich habe ja schon seit vielen Jahren jetzt immer mal wieder angerufen und Druck gemacht und gefragt, wann ist es endlich soweit? Und jetzt vielen Dank noch an meinen Anwalt, dass wir es endlich hinbekommen haben. Ich freue mich sehr da zu sein.
Ja, wir freuen uns auch. Und dann darf ich ja einen Rückkehrer im Rasenfunk begrüßen. Sebastian Zobel vom SWR-Sportpodcast Nur der FCK ist auch dabei. Hallo Sebastian.
Hi, bei mir hat es auch ohne Anwalt geklappt.
Ja, gut, manche mit, manche ohne. Aber bevor wir auf eure Vereine blicken, wollen wir als erstes ein bisschen auf die Lage der Liga schauen. Da ist nicht nur in den letzten drei Wochen ein bisschen was passiert, sondern auch heute. Also ich wollte eigentlich sagen, niemand ist entlassen worden. Das stand erst in meiner Anmoderation. Aber es ist vielleicht kein Trainer entlassen worden. Aber bei Nürnberg, da gab es heute den großen, großen Knall. Und zwar ist Olaf Reber als Sportdirektor entlassen worden. Es gibt diverse Gerüchte. Um diesen Abschied von Reber, ich glaube, wir können sagen, hinter den Kulissen ist es da durchaus zu Vorkommnissen gekommen, die so nicht mehr tragbar waren. Aber Sebastian ist ein bisschen überraschend, war es ja per se rein sportlich gesehen schon, wenn man so ein bisschen die Transfers von Nürnberg verfolgt hat.
Absolut. Also hat mich schon gewundert. Ich muss aber auch zugeben, ich bin jetzt beim Club nicht so intensiv drin, um jetzt vielleicht nachvollziehen zu können, ob es da schon länger irgendwie gebrodelt hat. Jetzt ist ja irgendwie wohl bekannt geworden, dass es da Stress mit einem Journalisten wohl gegeben haben soll. Aber das muss ja dann meiner Meinung nach schon irgendwie eine krasse Nummer gewesen sein. Und ich kann mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen, dass nur eine Streitigkeit, ein Wortgefecht oder was auch immer, das dann war mit einem Journalisten dazu führt, dass man einen Sportdirektor entlässt. Von daher könnte ich mir vorstellen, aber das ist jetzt reine Mutmaßung, dass da irgendwie vorher schon was am brodeln war und das jetzt quasi das berühmte Fass zum Überlaufen gebracht hat. Aber ja, wie du sagst, rein sportlich gesehen und ich sag mal, das, was er an Kohle rein geholt hat für den Club, da kann eigentlich keiner mit unzufrieden sein.
Ja, definitiv. Also wenn wir gerade von Kohle sprechen, nur mal ein paar Zahlen. Also unter anderem 25 Millionen für Ziemars, 4 Millionen für Karstrop und 8 Millionen für Jelsch. Also es ist ganz schön wie Kohle, die da reingekommen ist beim Club, der es sicherlich auch gut gebrauchen kann. Werden wir sicherlich beobachten, was da dann auch passiert. Also Schatzi Alett hat dann gesagt, die über eine Nachfolgeregelung wird zeitnah informiert werden. Sind wir auf jeden Fall gespannt. Aber so ganz ruhig bleibt es da, was auch immer am Ende der Grund war, scheint auch nicht beim Club. Aber Nils, das ist ja nicht das Einzige, was in der Liga gerade so los war. Was ist für dich momentan so das Thema in Liga 2?
Also um ehrlich zu sein, ist natürlich der ASV immer mein Thema. Und die Liga 2 wird durch den HSV so interessant. Aber sie hat auch ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal, nämlich sie ist unfassbar spannend. Und das nicht nur jetzt um vereinzene Platzierungen, sondern im Prinzip hast du von Platz 1 bis, je nachdem, zu welchem Spieltag man gerade auf die Tabelle schaut, bis runter Platz 10 meinetwegen, hast du Vereine, die um den Aufstieg kämpfen und du hast jede Woche ein anderes Tabellenbild. Aus diesen ersten 10 war gefühlt jeder schon mal auf Platz 1 mit teilweise einem sehr komfortablen Vorsprung, ob das jetzt Düsseldorf ist oder Paderborn oder Karlsruhe, jeder war schon mal gefühlt da oben mit dabei. Und dadurch, dass die auch ständig gegeneinander spielen, kann sich wirklich innerhalb von zwei, drei Spieltagen das komplette Tabellenbild wandeln und das ist natürlich total spannend. Und du hast dann auch, wenn man es mit einem eigenen Verein hält, was bei mir ja nun mal der HSV ist, hat man halt auch die Situation, dass man an jedem Spieltag auf andere Plätze schaut und sich denkt, oh, das wäre jetzt mein Wunschergebnis da und das, oh ja, unentschieden würde ich da mitnehmen. Also auch da ist immer schon Interesse auf jeden Fall.
Ja, kleine Ergänzung, einfach weil das unsere letzten beiden Vereine waren. Wir hatten hier lange drüber geredet, dass Braunschweig kein Tor schießen kann und sie haben seitdem aber gemacht. Es ist der Rasenfunk-Effekt, möchte ich nennen.
Okay, warte mal, was muss ich jetzt, welchen Effekt habt ihr jetzt auf den HSV? Das will ich vorher abklären.
Ich möchte, wir haben über Anwälte gesprochen, der meldet sich dann glaube ich bei mir, wenn ich jetzt irgendwas verspreche.
Du musst ganz oft sagen, dass der HSV nicht in seinen Frühjahrstief verfällt. Das war doch immer so Richtung März, oder? Ja, das ist der HSV.
Ja, aber muss ich sagen, dass es passiert oder dass es nicht passiert?
Das ist jetzt die Frage.
Das ist schon recht wichtig. Wir müssen ja über vergangene Probleme reden. Also wir dürfen nichts projizieren. Hier gibt es keine Zukunftsprognosen. Prinzipiell nicht. Wissen wir ja. Nee, aber um das zu ergänzen, also vier Tore in den letzten drei Spielen bei Braunschweig, dann der 2-0 Sieg gegen Karlsruhe am Wochenende inklusive. Also hätten wir nicht dieses ganze Fürth Magdeburg Spiel gehabt, wäre das für mich der kurioseste Handelfmeter der Saison wahrscheinlich gewesen. Für die, die es nicht gesehen haben, kauft man, reklamiert faul, nach einer Offensivaktion von Braunschweig und sitzt halt auf dem Boden und hebt den Manuel Neuer Reklamierarm, könnte man fast sagen, und kriegt dann den Ball an die Hand und es gibt Handelfmeter. Keine Ahnung, hatte ich vorher so auch noch nie gesehen. Ich glaube, regeltechnisch ist es halt in Ordnung. Ich glaube einfach, dass da dem Schiedsrichter nicht viel anderes übrig bleibt, weil er halt nicht gefault wurde. Also es war einfach kein Faul und dann hat er halt die Hand oben und verhindert halt im Zweifel eine Torchance. Also ja, es war eine klassische Loose-Loose-Situation für die Karlsruhe, glaube ich. Und Hertha, über die hatten wir nämlich auch gesprochen vor drei Wochen. Die sind inzwischen auf Rang 13 abgerutscht, zuletzt drei Niederlagen in Folge. Also wenn wir vor drei Wochen noch ein bisschen über Ausstieg gesprochen haben, ist das jetzt irgendwie ganz anders, weil man unter anderem eben auch gegen Jan Regensburg verloren hat, die ja immer noch tabellen Letzte sind und jetzt nur noch in Anführungszeichen sieben Punkte Abstand auf Platz 16 hat. Also da ist auch, ich weiß nicht, wie blickt ihr gerade auf die Hertha? Da ist dann ja auch immer großes Chaos.
Also der SCK hat ja gerade bei der Hertha gewonnen, von daher sind die Eindrücke noch recht frisch. Und da muss man schon sagen, dass das ein relativ unverdienter SCK-Sieg war. Also so ehrlich muss man schon sein, wer das gesehen hat. Also die Hertha war da schon über weite Strecken spielbestimmt. Und also das Tor, das ist dann halt auch so, das ist jetzt nicht, ja, also ich weiß nicht, in wieviel, wahrscheinlich in neun oder acht von zehn Fällen geht der Schuss so nicht rein. Und jetzt hat der SCK halt einen Lauf und vor allem Luca Zierch hat einen Lauf, zieht das Ding und dann macht er das Ding rein. Von daher, das muss man schon sagen, die Hertha ist, glaube ich, nicht ganz so schlecht, wie sie im Moment dasteht und hat auch tatsächlich bei dem Spiel nicht so schlecht abgeliefert, hatte auch das Pech, dass das Kral der Torwart vom FCK einen ziemlichen Sahnetag hatte.
Ja, ich glaube, für viele Hertha-Fans war gar nicht mal dieser 1-0-Niederlage gegen Kaiserslautern das Problem, sondern wirklich dieses 2-0 gegen Regensburg. Das haben sie nämlich hochverdient verloren, muss man schon so sagen. Also das war, ja, ich glaube bodenlos trifft es ganz gut in vielerlei Hinsicht. Also das war einfach keine gute Leistung und dann kommt man halt automatisch in so eine Abwärtsspirale, weil man immer in der zweiten Liga, sie ist eng, aber auch weil man durch Serien natürlich, das ist auch das Wort, was hier glaube ich am meisten genutzt wird in diesem Podcast, ja einfach super schnell in beide Richtungen rutschen kann und das passiert der Hertha halt einfach gerade, glaube ich.
Ich glaube auch, dass so zum Rückrundenbeginn kann ich mir vorstellen, dass sie sich so über den Winter gesagt haben, ey komm Leute, da ist noch nichts verloren, wenn wir jetzt wirklich wie du sagst in eine Serie starten, dann können wir da oben noch mal anknüpfen und wer weiß was passiert, dann kommt ein Fabi Reese zurück und dann ist es eine andere Mannschaft und dann haben sie halt gegen den HSV Pech gehabt, da holen sie ein 2-0 auf und sind dann am Drücker das 3-2 zu machen und kriegen dann mit einem Konter das 2 zu 3. Ich glaube das war richtiger Nackenschlag. Ich kann mir vorstellen, die haben sich eine Menge vorgenommen und dann diese völlig unnötige Niederlage gegen Regensburg und damit war ja dann die Saison auch vorbei. Also da jetzt noch diesen Rückstand aufzuholen ist relativ utopisch, insbesondere weil es ja nicht nur zwei, drei Mannschaften sind, die vor einem stehen, sondern zehn und die werden ja nicht alle härter den Gefallen tun noch einzubrechen. Das ist ja rein mathematisch vermutlich überhaupt nicht möglich. Von daher ist die Saison jetzt vorbei. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie noch absteigen. Sie müssen sich natürlich noch ein paar Punkte sichern. Aber das ist dann, wenn du jetzt schon am 21. Spieltag ein Fazit ziehen kannst, nämlich dass du nicht aufsteigst, ist das schon, auch wenn viele immer sagen, ja ist ein Umbruch und viele verletzt und es stimmt alles, aber es ist immer noch härter BSC und ich glaube der Anspruch ist schon zumindest mal möglichst lange um den Aufstieg mitzuspielen. Und von daher ist das eigentlich echt eine richtige Enttäuschung.
Ja, gehe ich mit auch weil wir haben hier vor drei Wochen noch so ein bisschen auch das Finanzielle etc. angerissen, also da hängt natürlich auch das alles hinterher. Da wissen wir um die Probleme bei der Härter und weil man eben ja auch sieht, dass es natürlich nicht leichter wird, solange man in dieser zweiten Liga drin steckt. Reden wir bestimmt gleich noch drüber, Nils. Noch ein letzter Verein, den ich mir so aufgeschrieben hab, das ist Darmstadt 98. Sie haben es jetzt geschafft in zwei Spielen gegen Elbersberg, ich glaube sieben Tore zu kassieren, 0 zu 4 und 0 zu 3. Da war die Laune extrem schlecht am Böllentor am Wochenende. Das war schon, ja, also nicht gut und sie sind jetzt, also dieses Hoch, was sie am Anfang hatten, unter Kohfeldt, das ist ja irgendwie komplett weg. Also inzwischen ist man Platz 18 in der Jahrestabelle. Fair, das sind vier Spiele, also das sind noch nicht so viele, aber trotzdem erst ein Punkt in 2025. Da ist auf jeden Fall auch einige Probleme, aber es zeigt dem auch wieder. Du kannst dich eben nicht auf eine Serie ausruhen, es muss halt kontinuierlich weitergehen. Und ich glaube auch für die ist ein Teil der Saison einfach durch. Also ich kann mir jetzt auch nicht vorstellen, dass es für die weder in die eine noch in die andere Richtung richtig große Ausschläge noch gibt.
Definitiv. Ich finde, Darmstadt ist so dieses Beispiel oder eins der vielen Beispiele dafür, wie für dieses Motto der Liga, so jeder kann jeden schlagen. Man hat es irgendwie hundertmal gehört. Aber das ist so im Dezember hat Lautern da noch eine 5-1 Packung gefangen bei Darmstadt. Und wenn man jetzt auf die Tabelle guckt, denkt man, wie haben die das geschafft? Also von daher, das ist ja klar, Cofeld, ordentlicher Start. Aber was jetzt daraus geworden ist, die haben sicherlich auch höhere Ambitionen, vielleicht nicht ganz so krass wie die Hertha, aber die sehen sich selber sicherlich auch deutlich weiter vorne als sie es jetzt sind.
Ich glaube auch bei Darmstadt dieses Zwischenhoch, das ist ja so ein bisschen wie bei der Tour de France, wenn du so hinten dranhängst, willst eigentlich um den Sieg mitfahren und dann fährst du so die Lücke zu, zur Führungsgruppe und denkst, geil, jetzt bin ich dabei und kaum sind sie dran, müssen sie wieder abreißen lassen. Und dieses Kosten an dem Erfolg, das macht es auch so ein bisschen dramatisch, weil die jetzt ja nicht kontinuierlich auf einem gewissen Niveau spielen, sondern sie hatten einen katastrophalen Saisonstart, dann kam Florian Kohfeldt und dann kam mit ihm auch dieses völlig unvorhersehbare Hoch und dann haben sie ja wirklich super Fußball gespielt, viele Tore geschossen und waren eine der Spitzenmannschaften der Liga und waren dann auch wirklich dran. Und dann wieder so abzufallen, das ist ja enttäuschend, weil sie haben ja gezeigt, dass sie es können und sie hätten eine viel bessere Rolle spielen können und ich glaube, das kann ja auch vom Kopf her. Also wie ordnest du das ein? Ich glaube schon, dass man vor ein paar Wochen gedacht hat, ja wir greifen nochmal an.
Ja und dafür hatten sie ja quasi einen zu großen Rückstand am Anfang der Saison, der ja erstmal aufgeholt werden musste, als dass man das jetzt so leicht wegstecken kann. Das gehört natürlich auch dazu. Ich war nämlich das erste Mal, als ich dann irgendwie dachte, hä Cofeld, Darmstadt, warum gewinnt die so viel? Und dachte auch, dass ich sie dann zu dem Zeitpunkt schon viel höher in der Tabelle wiederfinde und dachte, ach so, die sind ja immer noch irgendwo im Mittelfeld unterwegs. Weil aber halt einfach nur die Distanz zu den Amstiegsrängen erst mal aufgebaut haben. Was ja damals erstmal das Ziel war, das darf man natürlich auch nicht vergessen. Also als Cofeld übernommen hat, war die Situation ja nun mal eine ganz andere. Aber jetzt ist eben, man hat irgendwie nicht die St. Pauli und Mainz Moves von vor ein paar Jahren geschafft, da wirklich dieses, auch vielleicht eine ganze Rückrunde irgendwie aufzubauen. Stand jetzt, also wir sind auch immer noch ein bisschen zu früh dran, glaube ich, um diese dann eine endgültiges Fazit zu ziehen. Aber ich glaube schon, dass was wir jetzt über die Härter und eben auch über Darmstadt gesagt haben, also da müssten schon viele Sachen passieren, dass sie da jetzt noch mal in diese in diese richtige Ausstiegsriege im Prinzip reinrutschen. Aber lass doch mal darüber sprechen, wer denn in dieser Ausstiegsriege momentan drin ist. Und das ist unter anderem der Hamburger SV. Momentan auf Platz zwei, 38 Punkte, 740 zu 28 Tore, 10 Siege, 8 unentschieden, 3 Niederlagen. Man ist punktgleich mit Kaiserslautern und eben gemeinsam mit Kaiserslautern zwei Punkte hinter Köln. Der Trainer, der ist seit offiziell seit dem 23.12. Merlin Polzin. Vorher war es ja Steffen Baumgart. Nils, wie ist denn die Laune beim HSV gerade?
Ich glaube die Laune ist, man muss sehr vorsichtig sein. Also man hat große Angst in Hamburg, irgendwas zu jinxen. Ob wir auf irgendeinem Friedhof gebaut haben, das Volksparkstadion und alte Geister dann immer eingreifen oder so. Man will auf keinen Fall irgendwas riskieren. Deswegen ist man sehr, sehr leid geplagt und natürlich dann auch sehr vorsichtig, was Erfolgsprognosen angeht. Aber momentan ist die Stimmung sehr gut, wie ich finde, weil man nach den Walter-Jahren und dann Steffen Baumgart jetzt eine Situation hat, dass man einen Trainer hat, der zum HSV gehört, vom HSV kommt, der super sympathisch ist und jung ist. Und also das ist ja genau das, was man eigentlich immer wollte, so ein Trainer wie Polzin. Und er hat natürlich jetzt für den Moment auch Erfolg, hat noch nicht ein Spiel verloren, hat einen sehr guten Schnitt. Es gibt ja so eine Polzin-Tabelle, da ist er glaube ich zweiter. Also er hat wirklich, ich weiß nicht, zweieinhalb Punkte im Schnitt oder was. Also obwohl er das jetzt nur die Rückgründe gerechnet davor war, ist es ein bisschen weniger. Aber die Stimmung ist gut bis sehr gut, würde ich mal sagen. Und es baut sich so langsam so ein Gefühl auf, könnte es dieses Jahr wirklich klappen? Und das liegt natürlich dann auch zum einen an der eigenen Stärke, aber auch am Rest der Liga. Weil wenn man jetzt zu Beginn der Saison geschaut hat, okay, wie sieht die Liga aus? Dann siehst du erst mal so einen Namen wie Donnerhall, dann siehst du den 1. FC Köln, du siehst Hertha, dann siehst du Schalke, aber auch dahinter Düsseldorf, die so knapp in der Relegation gescheitert waren, Hannover, die sehr, sehr ambitioniert sind. Und dann hast du immer noch Mannschaften wie Karlsruhe, Paderborn, die jederzeit in der Lage sind, so eine richtig gute Saison einfach mal rauszuhauen, mit der man vorher nicht unbedingt rechnen konnte. Das heißt, du kannst nicht davon ausgehen, dies Jahr gehst du hoch. Und aufgrund der Schwäche vieler Konkurrenten und auch der eigenen Stärke manifestiert sich so langsam der Glaube, Mensch, da könnte was werden. Das könnte was werden dieses Jahr. Deswegen bin ich ganz gut drauf.
Ja, also genau, um das zu verdeutlichen, also die Polzin-Tabelle, 18 Punkte in acht Spielen, also eben erst vier Spiele als Interimstrainer und dann eben als Trainer übernommen. Und nur Köln hat mehr Punkte geholt, also 19 in der Zeit. Also es ist schon sehr, sehr erfolgreich. Und es ist eben, ja ich gehe halt mit, dieses Polzin vielleicht genau der Trainer ist, den man jetzt irgendwie nach Walter und Baumgart auch brauchte. Also wir reden gleich nochmal ganz kurz darüber, warum es mit Baumgart nicht geklappt hat. Müssen wir nämlich auch ganz kurz machen. Aber halt keine Authentizität, die vorgespielt werden muss, hat man irgendwie so das Gefühl. Sondern einfach wirklich eine, die da ist. Wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe, war er Co-Trainer von Dani Thun auch und ist da ja auch lange unter ihm gewesen und ist dann eben auch geblieben, als Thun dann nicht mal beim HSV war. Und er passt da einfach irgendwie ganz gut zu. Und er hat natürlich eine Sache geschafft, die hat man vorher sehr, sehr lange nicht mehr geschafft. Es ist der erste Sieg am Freitagabend gegen Preußen Münster. Der erste Sieg ging ein Aufsteiger seit sechs Spielen gewesen. Seit sechs Spielen konnte man nicht mehr gegen einen Aufsteiger aus der Dritten Liga gewinnen. Und das sind ja eben diese Spiele, die hat man ja eigentlich immer in der Vergangenheit angesprochen. Das waren diese Spiele, die hat man nicht gewonnen oder sogar verloren. Und das waren am Ende immer so die, diese ein, zwei Punkte, die eben gefehlt haben für eine Platzierung, entweder unter den Top 2 oder sogar unter den Top 3. Und das ist ja, ja, das passt irgendwie. Aber bevor wir jetzt vielleicht über all die guten Dinge unter Polzin reden, lass uns doch einmal drauf gucken, warum ist denn deiner Meinung nach Steffen Baumgart beim Hals vorgescheitert?
Also ich glaube, das fing schon zu Beginn an, weil du hast dann da zweieinhalb Jahre Walther Fußball gehabt und die waren nicht nur indoktriniert, was so die Art des Spielens angeht, sondern es war auch so, dass Walther die Kabine nicht verloren hatte. Und das ist oft so bei Trainerwechseln, dass die Mannschaft schon durchblicken lässt, ich habe eigentlich keinen Bock mehr auf den, lass mal was Neues probieren. Und dann hat ein neuer Trainer auch eine sehr viel bessere Ausgangssituation, weil die Mannschaft sich eigentlich auch jemand Neues herbeigesehen hat und viele das dann auch als Chance begreifen oder auch als Befreiung verstehen, Mensch, jetzt können wir wieder richtig loslegen. Und ich glaube Baumgart von Anfang an war jetzt nicht ein Heilsbringer für die Mannschaft, weil die eigentlich mit Walther weitergemacht hätte. So das heißt, der kommt erst mal und wird erst mal so, ja okay, was ist das jetzt? Dann ist aber auch klar gewesen, dass er nicht die erste Wahl war, denn er war auf dem Markt und natürlich wurde er gefragt in der Zwischenzeit und hat auch verlauten lassen, ja, theoretisch, ich bin bereit. Und dass er dann nicht sofort gekommen ist, lag daran, dass zu der Zeit noch ein Jonas Bolt gar nicht wirklich von ihm überzeugt war, eventuell wurde der Druck dann zu hoch. Also es war nicht die Wunschlösung und so ist er dann auch reingestartet. Und dann hat man halt gemerkt, dass auch von seinen Umstellungen her die Mannschaft sich sehr schwer getan hat. Er will ja eigentlich Viererkette spielen, trifft oft, bekommt dann eine Mannschaft, die seit Jahren Viererkette spielt und probiert es dann mit einer Fünferkette. Und die Ergebnisse sind ausgeblieben. Die Art des Spiels war unattraktiv. Und du hast richtig gemerkt, dass so das Muskelgedächtnis der Spieler so massiv gefremdelt hat mit der Art, wie Baumgart Fußball spielen möchte. Das hat leider hinten und vorne nicht funktioniert. Und auch so diese energetische Batteriefunktion, die er auch in Köln immer an der Seitenlinie dann ausgeübt hat, wo man das Gefühl hat, okay, die Power von Baumgart, die überträgt sich irgendwie und die machen nur noch Pressing und gehen rauf. Das hat nicht funktioniert, weil die Mannschaft phasenweise so passiv war unter Baumgart, auch nach einer Führung einfach nichts mehr gemacht hat. Man hatte das Gefühl, die Mannschaft weiß überhaupt nicht, was jetzt von ihr erwartet wird. Die haben alles eingestellt und drum gebettelt, dass der Gegner zurückkommt. Das schlimmste Beispiel war für mich das Schalke-Spiel. Als sie da 2-0 führen, Schalke war Mause tot. Schalke war wie Brasilien damals beim 1-7. Du konntest dabei zusehen, wie die zusammenklappen. Aber der HSV hat dann einfach nichts mehr gemacht und Schalke wieder eingeladen und diese tote Mannschaft zurückgebracht. Und das war Baumgart Fußball. Das hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert und wurde dann auch folgerichtlich korrigiert. Und Paul Zien hat ja auch schon unter Walter Co-Trainer gemacht. Der hatte halt ganz viele von dem noch in sich und versteht auch, was die Mannschaft da gelernt hat, welche Abläufe und was die gut können. Der kennt die in- und auswendig, die Jungs. Und hat aber jetzt auch das Selbstbewusstsein und auch das Mandat, seinen eigenen Stil anzubringen und jetzt nicht irgendwas zu kopieren, sondern er will sich jetzt auch selbst als Fußballlehrer positionieren und zeigen, was er drauf hat. Er hat jetzt seinen offiziellen Fußballlehrerschein ja gemacht. Und jetzt beginnt so seine Karriere und ich glaube, dass er jetzt auch durch die jüngsten Erfolge auch ein Standing hat und Selbstbewusstsein hat, was dazu beiträgt, dass er auch so eine Festigkeit und Glaubwürdigkeit auch in der Mannschaft hat. Deswegen bin ich guter Dinge.
Aber wie sehr glaubst du, dass Polzin, also er kann ja eigentlich nicht die 1A-Lösung gewesen sein, weil man hat ja schon so ein bisschen mitbekommen, dass Stefan Kunz doch bei dem ein oder anderen Kandidaten vielleicht auch angefragt hat zwischendurch.
Muss das hier einmal kurz Stefan Kunz mention, ich habe diesen tollen Becher für die Puppen.
Boah, Amina Bielefeld.
Ja, genau, das schöne alte Gerry Weber-Trikot Stefan Kunz mention. Muss ich einmal kurz haben.
Also da frage ich mich, also geiler Becher, definitiv. Müssen wir appreciaten, soll nicht untergehen. Aber ich frage mich immer, wie das dann für jemanden ist, wenn das ja dann, ich meine, es kommt ja immer irgendwie raus und du merkst das ja dann, also Polzin merkt das ja selber dann auch, dass sie, weiß ich nicht, erst am Anfang nur so halb vielleicht hinter ihm gestanden haben. Also was darfst du?
Naja, also erstmal, er hat ja schon damals interheamsweise übernommen, als Walter entlassen wurde und dann Baumgart kam und da hat man sich schon so ein bisschen ein Bild auch von ihm machen können. Er hat damals nur ein Spiel gehabt, das Auswärtsspiel in Rostock. Das lief dann nicht so gut. Und dass man dann in so einer Situation, wo du als HSV sagst, okay, du willst dieses Jahr aufsteigen, da überlegt, okay, ich nehme jetzt vielleicht jemanden, der etwas gestandener ist, der schon etwas nachgewiesen hat. Ist ja auch verständlich, weil natürlich ist das ein Experiment. Und ich glaube, dass es weniger das Potenzial ist, was man dem Trainer gesehen hat, sondern vielleicht auch das, was ihm fehlt, nämlich Erfahrung und Nachweis, dass er eine Mannschaft führen kann, auch dann, wenn es mal kriselt oder wenn der Druck hoch ist. Das hat Polzin natürlich noch nicht unter Beweis stellen können, weil es seine erste Trainerstation ist. Und ich würde jetzt an Polzins Stelle das überhaupt nicht persönlich nehmen oder als Zweifel an meinen Fähigkeiten verstehen, sondern einfach ganz klar, okay, ich stehe am Anfang der Karriere. Er hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt gar nicht mal seinen Fußballlehrer fertig. Und jetzt hat er die Chance bekommen und sollte jetzt versuchen, diese Chance auch zu nutzen und nicht irgendwie zu glauben, ich bin die zweite, dritte Wahl. Natürlich hat der ASV sich bei anderen Kandidaten umgesehen. Und wenn jemand zugesagt hätte oder jetzt, was ich in Kwasniok nicht vom Verein ein Riegel vorgeschoben bekommen hätte, dann wäre wahrscheinlich heute auch nicht Polzin der Trainer. Aber ich meine, es liegt ja an ihm, das vergessen zu machen. Guck dir mal Vincent Kompany an. Der war die 28. Wahl bei Bayern, wurde über Wochen diese Trainersuche mit Sport begleitet und hat sich sehr, sehr schnell freigeschwommen von diesem Makel. Und heute redete eigentlich keiner mehr drüber, auf welchen Listenplatz er in er hatte. Und die Chance hat Polzin auch. Und das muss man sagen, er hat es ja auch sehr gut genutzt in den ersten Wochen.
Ich finde ja, dass auch wenn das jetzt nicht primär unser Thema ist, aber ich fand ja die Nummer, wie Kwasniok dann auch reagiert hat und dass er das so öffentlich gemacht hat, sein Frust darüber, dass er jetzt wieder eine Anfrage hatte, wieder nicht freigestellt wurde, das fand ich irgendwie auch krass. Also finde ich auch schwierig damit umzugehen, auch von Vereinsseite aus, wenn dein Trainer so offen damit umgeht, dass er eigentlich gerne was anderes gemacht hätte.
Ja und ich finde dann ja, ich finde dann ja auch fast, kann man vielleicht sagen, ob HSV dann nicht fast Glück hatte, dass er nicht diese Freistellung bekommen hat. Weil ich fand Kwasniok fast die zu offensichtlichste Wahl. Man ist dann ja fast wieder in dieses, also nichts gegen Kwasniok und auch nicht gegen Walter und auch nicht gegen Baumgart. Aber dann hätte man jetzt wieder einen Trainer genommen, der ja vor allem, also jetzt mal Köln ausgeklammert, aber mit so einem Verein erst mal Erfolg hatte und auch aufgestiegen ist, wo halt vielleicht nicht der klassische Druck hintersteckt, wie halt bei einem HSV. So oder halt eben auch bei einem FC Köln am Baumgartstelle. Und ich hätte fast Schiss gehabt, dass man da wieder in das gleiche Muster reingerutscht wäre. Also dass man da einen Trainer verpflichtet hätte, der eine gewisse Spielidee aus Paderborn mitbringt, die auch erfolgreich ist, aber wo man ja auch hätte wieder ins offene Messer laufen können. Und vielleicht ist Paul Zien dahingegangen. Ich meine, der hat eben auch einfach diverse Trainer beim HSV mitgemacht. Also jahrelang noch nicht mehr so viele, wie es mal eine Zeit lang war. Also er hat dann ja durchaus auch die Kontinuität von Tim Walther mitgetragen. Er hat eben auch die Jungen kennengelernt und dann diese kurze Zeit vom Baumgart. Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass er da vieles gelernt hat auch einfach. Also was, welche Punkte vielleicht im Training wichtig sind, was er außerhalb vom Training bringen muss, wie er die Mannschaft vielleicht ja motivieren kann. Und was er glaube ich ganz wichtig weiß, ich meine wir haben aus Spaß eben schon mal diese ganze Frühlingsthematik angesprochen. Der war da ja selber psychisch mit dabei und ich glaube, das darf man nicht unterschätzen. Also dass da selber einer jetzt an der Seitenlinie steht, der das zwar nicht als Haupttrainer mitgetragen hat, aber als Co-Trainer eben auch unter verschiedenen Trainern. Und der glaube ich vielleicht auch da seine eigene Strategie mit hat. Und da bin ich mal tatsächlich gespannt, weil ich wirklich finde, es ist für mich immer noch kein wahnsinnig großer Hurra-Fußball. Also es gibt Spiele, die sind schöner anzusehen vom HSV und manche, wo du einfach sagst, ja aber sie gewinnen sie halt einfach. Also dieses Spiel gegen Münster haben sie einfach gewonnen. So und einfach weil ich das Gefühl habe, sie schaffen es endlich ihre individuelle Klasse so auszuspielen, dass es von vorne bis hinten passt und dass man einfach Davy Selke dazu geholt hat und dass der jetzt eben nicht so lange ausgefallen ist, wie man vielleicht befürchtet hat erst, sondern dass er mit Maske spielen kann. Und man jetzt eben nicht nur Glatzel da vorne drin hat, sondern dass du halt mit Selke, Königsdörfer und Glatzel eigentlich, wer Glatzel nicht auch verletzt, aber sonst eigentlich diese oder drei Spielertypen eigentlich vorne hast, die gar nicht mal eins zu eins die gleichen sind, sondern unterschiedliche Qualitäten mitbringen und daher aber einfach diese Vielfalt vorne drin hat. Und ich glaube, das sind alles so kleine Puzzlestücke, wo ich einfach auch selbst ich optimistischer bin von außen.
Ich oute mich. Ich hätte es Davy Selke niemals zugetraut, dass er so performt beim HSV. Niemals. Never ever. Also der überrascht mich jetzt echt.
Haben viele nicht. Und ich hab wenig Ahnung von Fußball und Dingen im Allgemeinen, aber ich war ich tatsächlich, war ich mir sicher und ich hab mit vielen Leuten diskutiert, im Internet oder auch in der Familie mit meinem Vater, der seit whatever, er ist halt schon ein bisschen älter, vielen Jahrzehnten HSV-Fan ist und die wenigsten hätten das gedacht und die wenigsten hätten sportlich gedacht, aber die wenigsten hätten auch gedacht, dass er charakterlich gut zum HSV passt und er zeigt jetzt nämlich, dass er in beiden Aspekten sehr wichtig ist. Zum einen wird er jetzt auch richtig eingesetzt. Wir haben ja auch über Baumgart gesprochen, der ja auch eine Geschichte hat mit Selke und der auch in Köln pro Spiel 50 Flanken hat schlagen lassen. Und beim HSV eigentlich gar nicht. Da gab es halt auch diese Situation, wo die sich so weit zurückgezogen haben, dass ein David Selke da als einsamer Anläufer an der Mittellinie irgendwo steht und versucht in Ballnähe zu kommen und war komplett verschenkt. Und jetzt unter Polzin versuchst du den halt auch so einzusetzen, wie er eingesetzt werden muss. Das ist halt ein Strafraumstürmer und dem musst du halt Bälle geben. Und der ist ja einer der besten Kopfballspieler der Liga. Der hat ja keinen Verteidiger, hat Bock gegen einen David Selke zu spielen. Und wenn er dann auch so eingesetzt wird, dann funktioniert er und dann scoret er. Und dann macht er auch, so schwer es zu sein scheint, einen Robert Latzel fürs erste ein bisschen vergessen. Da fehlt einfach mal der beste Stürmer der 2. Liga seit Monaten verletzt beim HSV. Und wir müssen nicht darüber reden, weil David Selke das eben schafft, diese Lücke zu füllen. Und man hat es jetzt auch gegen Hannover gesehen, als er dieses eine Spiel gefehlt hat, dass so ein Spielertyp überhaupt nicht zu ersetzen ist, weil da ein Wahn-Königsdörfer vorne drin, aber der konnte keine langen Bälle festmachen, den konntest du nicht mit Flanken füttern. Der hat kein katastrophales Kopfballspiel Königsdörfer, aber natürlich im Vergleich mit Selke kackt da jeder ab. Und Hannover ist früh raufgegangen, hat früh gepresst und dann kam halt viele lange Bälle auch mal raus und dann fehlt halt ein Davi Selke, der die auch mal festmacht und die dann verteilt. Und das ist seine sportliche Wichtigkeit, aber auch charakterlich. Das ist halt ein Gewinner-Typ und viele, wenn er nicht im eigenen Verein spielt, finden ihn irgendwie assi. Aber wenn er bei einem spielt, der Typ der bringt eine super positive Gewinner-Mentalität mit. Und ich hab den richtig ins Herz geschlossen. Und das ist ein ganz wichtiges Puzzlestück, weil du ja von auch über so Frühjahrskrisen, die ja eigentlich nur mental zu erklären sind, gesprochen hast. Und das ist ein Typ, von dem ich glaube, dass er einen ganz, ganz wichtigen Einfluss hat, auch was die Mentalität angeht.
Ja, und das ist natürlich, was dann auch wichtig war, er hat gegen Hannover gefehlt. Aber man hat eben auch dieses Spiel nicht verloren. Sondern man hat eben unentschieden gespielt. Ich glaube, 2-2 ist es ausgegangen. Und das ist ja auch wichtig. Also klar, du hast vielleicht zwei Punkte liegen lassen, aber du hast vor allem nicht drei Punkte verloren. So und ich glaube, das ist auch so was kommt ja alles mit da rein. Und dann hast du natürlich über noch einen Jean-Luc Dompe dabei. Meistens Scorer-Punkte beim HSV, auch sechs Tore selber, ach das ist. Aber er kam zu spät zum Training. Und dann setzt ihn Polzin auch gegen Münster erst mal eine Halbzeit auf der Bank. Und das hat er glaube ich die Woche davor oder so auch schon mit Zaiti gemacht. Er hatte halt schon noch dieses, okay, wir kennen uns jetzt ein bisschen und ich war lange Co-Trainer, aber ich bin jetzt Trainer und ich habe Regeln, die ihr bitte befolgt und das und das sind meine Standards. Es geht nicht darum, da rum zu reiten, sondern einfach zu sagen so, hey passiert ist in Ordnung, aber so eine kleine Disziplinarmaßnahme bringe ich jetzt trotzdem an. Wir schaffen das hier nur gemeinsam. Und klar, man muss das jetzt auch nicht überpushen, aber ich glaube, das sind alles so kleine Sachen, die helfen Polizien auch einfach sich als Führungspersönlichkeit zu stärken.
Genau, wir hatten es vorhin davon, ob man die Kabine hinter sich hat oder nicht. Und ich glaube, mit so Sachen verschaffst du dir halt echt Respekt. Fußball ist halt wirklich so ein Ding. Da ist das Thema Respekt, Hierarchien, Regeln, das ist einfach ein großes. Und daran müssen sich alle halten. Und ich glaube, wenn du das für irgendwelche Einzelspieler aufweichst, dann wird dir das halt negativ ausgelegt. Und so merkt halt jeder, okay, an sich wahrscheinlich, also zumindest schätze ich ihn so ein, das Polizien eher so der, weiß jetzt nicht ob Kumpeltyp das trifft, aber ich schätze, der kommt zumindest jetzt nicht so rüber, als wäre er da, der würde einen auch fanchral machen, aber dass er halt trotzdem einfach seine Regeln hat und dann durchgreift und so behältst du halt die Kabine.
Ja, und dann hast du zwar eine Defensive, die jetzt nicht die beste, aber zumindest die viertbeste der Liga ist, so und wo ja einfach also gefühlt war für mich immer gerade auch die Defensive beim HSV, die wurde irgendwann zu einem großen Problem, einfach weil es viel Rotation gab, weil man irgendwie immer wieder verletzt hat. Also jetzt wird ja glaube ich schon langsam wieder in dieses, als Kapitän auch wieder da eingearbeitet. Du wusstest nie, wer geht da dann irgendwie vorne vorweg. Über Vuskovic haben wir da noch gar nicht gesprochen. Und da ist es aber auch so, man hat relativ wenig zu Null Spiele, aber man kassiert halt trotzdem nicht so viele Tore. Also es ist halt, zwar hast du jetzt nicht diese Menge an 3-4-0-Siegen oder so, aber du hast halt einfach trotzdem eine stabile Defensive. Und ich glaube, der Mix, der kann es halt wirklich werden am Ende, dass du da nicht der Beste bist, aber trotzdem einfach stabil.
Also sie sind schon, vom Torverhältnis her, sie haben die meisten Tore und zwar mit Abstand. Na gut, Magdeburg hat drei weniger, aber es ist halt trotzdem 47 Tore geschossen. Und dann halt die erste und dann die vierte beste Abwehr. Sie sind schon auf jeden Fall gute Zahlen, weil oftmals geht ja das eine auf Kosten der anderen. Also Sebastian, du willst was sagen?
Ja, also weil wir jetzt schon wieder ein bisschen weiter sind, passt es gar nicht mehr so gut. Aber ich wollte noch eine Sache zu Devi Selke sagen, weil du das auch angesprochen hast. Ich wollte dir nämlich auch noch recht geben, dass das wirklich so ein Spielertyp ist. Wenn der nicht in deiner Mannschaft ist und du den als Gegner beobachtest oder auch als neutraler Zuschauer, dann ist das jemand, der polarisiert halt und der act total an. Und viele haben glaube ich echt so, also mögen den einfach nicht, auch wenn es eigentlich keinen wirklich krassen Grund dafür gibt. Aber die sehen ihn, wie er aufkritt und haben deswegen nicht so Bock auf den. Aber das ist genauso ein Spielertyp, wie du ihn halt in der Mannschaft brauchst. Du hast jetzt auch schon einiges so gesagt, aber du brauchst, ich sag das immer, du brauchst auch, so dumm wie es klingt, aber du brauchst auch ein Arschloch in der Mannschaft. Das ist was Selke beim HSV ist, das ist Marlon Ritter beim FCK. Du brauchst solche Leute, die anecken, die auf dem Platz einfach eklig sind, giftig sind und die unbedingt gewinnen wollen und dafür alles machen. Also ich rede jetzt wirklich nicht davon irgendwie unfair zu spielen oder so. Ich glaube klar, der ein oder andere Trick und mal ein dummer Spruch, das gehört dazu, Trash Talk war jetzt gerade im DFB-Pokal auch großes Thema zwischen Leverkusen und Köln, aber solange sich das alles im legalen Bereich bewegt, ist alles gut. Aber das ist einfach was, das merken ja auch, das merken die Zuschauer, das nimmt die Zuschauer total mit, wenn da so einer ist, der sich super damit identifiziert, der vorweggeht, der motiviert ist, der unbedingt gewinnen will und die Mitspieler merken das auch. Und von daher hat er da diese Lücke von Glatzel super, super ausgefüllt.
Ja, ich finde auch, er hat nochmal eine andere Mentalität als Glatzel. Also dieses, was du ansprichst, man darf halt nicht zu nett sein. Du gewinnst mit Nettigkeit gar nichts. Egal wie viel der ist, du musst halt dieses Spiel gucken. Bestes Beispiel dieses auf die Spitze 3 ist der Atletico Madrid, die ja zu 30 Prozent aus Asich bestehen. Und ein bisschen davon brauchst du halt und selge auch, wie er das vor dem Elfmeter gemacht hat. Also das 2 zu 1. Jetzt in Münster in der Nachspielzeit, dieser Elfmeter, den er bekommen hat, wo den auch nicht jeder pfeift, aber wie er das einfach macht. Er sich da so mit dem Gegenspieler rangeln und dann zu Boden gehen und so weiter. Das ist eine Art von dreckigem Reinwühlen. Das macht halt auch nicht jeder auf diese Art und Weise. Ganz bewusst so einen Zweikampf so auf die Art tun. Ja, lass uns nicht zu viel über David, weil ich könnte jetzt wirklich lange über Selke sprechen, aber wir waren eigentlich schon weg, wir waren schon bei der Defensive. Und da wollte ich nochmal auch eine andere Personalie erwähnen, einen weiteren Neuzugang, der sehr sehr wichtig ist, aber natürlich so ein bisschen immer, weil er nicht so spektakulär ist wie den Selke, vielleicht nicht als erstes genannt wird, das ist ein Daniel El-Fatli, der kam aus Magdeburg und der hätte eigentlich schon letztes Jahr kommen sollen. Und der hat einen richtig krassen Impact auf die Defensive, weil der kann In-Verteidiger spielen und Sechser. Und er wird auch einem Schonlau vorgezogen und er wird auch einem Meffat vorgezogen. Das sind so zwei Spieler, wo man in der Vergangenheit immer dachte, okay, da sollte tunlich keiner von den beiden fehlen. Und jetzt sind die beide ersetzbar geworden. Gerade ein Meffat hatte so Statistiken, ohne den gewinnste nichts. Und jetzt auf einmal ist dann El-Fatli. Und ja, wenn man den letztes Jahr schon bekommen hätte, Magdeburg hat ihn nicht ziehen lassen, zu Recht, wie man jetzt merkt, vielleicht wären das die paar Punkte gewesen, die dann auch letztes Jahr schon zum Erfolg geführt hätten, nämlich zum Aufstieg. Also das ist auch ein sehr, sehr starker Neuzugang.
Ja und er kommt natürlich auch mit einer, ja, aus einem System, was natürlich auch klar ist unter Tietz. Und ich glaube, er braucht das aber auch. Also dass er dann wirklich wieder auch unter einem Trainer spielt, der auch ein klares Defensivsystem hat. Und das finde ich halt schon, dass man das bei Polzin erkennen kann und dass er eben schon so versucht, sich da seine perfekte Defensive zu formen. Und ich finde, das konnte man jetzt eigentlich auch bisher jetzt unter ihm ganz gut sehen. Ich glaube, es ist einfach, ja, ich meine, die einmal nur kurz, weil ich Vuskovic eben angesprochen habe, weil heute eben da auch nochmal neue News reinkamen, der ist ja irgendwie nochmal vor das Schweizer Bundesgericht gezogen mit dem Einspruch, der wurde aber eben auch abgewiesen, was eigentlich schon relativ klar war, weil es, glaube ich, keine neue Beweislage gab oder keine neuen Beweise, die ihn da auch irgendwie klar entlasten könnten. Ich glaube, diese ganze Thematik wurde hier auch schon mal gesprochen mit Tanja, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Also deshalb hatte ich das hier jetzt auch eher kurz gehalten, weil ich glaube, das brauchen, das wäre, glaube ich, fast eine eigene Sendung, irgendwie über diese ganze Thematik darum zu sprechen. Aber da finde ich auch einfach, fand ich damals das Zeichenformat ISV so stark, also zu sagen, okay, den bis 2025 gültigen Vertrag, den lösen wir auf, weil es beiden Seiten nicht wirklich viel bringt, aber gleichzeitig eine Vertragsverlängerung ab 2026 verkündet. Und damals, glaube ich, auch als komplette Mannschaft irgendwie oder als Teil einer Mannschaft ihn da irgendwie in Split besucht und so. Also ich glaube eben auch, das ist der HSV jetzt, also dieser Zusammenhalt, der eben auch existiert. Und ja, witzigerweise, das, was ja eigentlich immer so die ganzen kleineren Vereine in Anführungszeichen früher auch zum Aufstieg gebracht hat. Also, dass man durch mannschaftliche Geschlossenheit durch ja vielleicht mal auch dreckige Sieger etc. und dieses Gesamtpaket aufgestiegen ist. Und ich finde, das sieht man halt beim HSV inzwischen.
Ja, denke ich auch. Also die Mannschaft scheint auf jeden Fall intakt zu sein. Und sie ist ja auch im großen Teil zusammengeblieben. Man hat natürlich mit Laszlo Benic den besten Spieler der vorangehenden Saison verloren, aber auch niemanden sonst. Also oft ist es ja so, wenn du dein Ziel über Jahre nicht erreichst, irgendwann bricht dann diese Mannschaft zusammen. Wohingegen die meisten Mannschaften, die aufsteigen ja eher welche sind, wo du Kontinuität siehst, sowohl auf dem Platz als auch auf der Trainerbank. Und das ist natürlich wirklich ein Vorteil, dass man die Mannschaft halten konnte. Dass eben ein Glatzel geblieben ist als Beispiel oder ein Doppé geblieben ist. Das stimmt wohl. Ja, genau und Vuskovic, darauf wollte ich noch kurz überlegen, den kann man natürlich sportlich nicht mehr in irgendeiner Form mit hinzuzählen. Also selbst wenn er jetzt freigesprochen wäre gegen jede Wahrscheinlichkeit, ich glaube sein Anwalt hatte drei Prozent Chance gegeben, dass das irgendwie klappt. Also es war schon absehbar, dass das nicht funktioniert. Denn selbst dann wäre ja an den Vuskovic auch keine Sofort-Verstärkung. Da müsste er erstmal wieder an den Leistungssport herangeführt werden. Von daher muss man sich natürlich so aufstellen, dass man da auch nicht mit ihm rechnet. Und das macht der HSV, die haben ja auch noch mal nachgelegt in der Winterpause, jetzt in der Innenverteidigung jemanden geholt, was eben auch dafür spricht, dass man so diese Konstellationen aus Hazikatunic und Schornlau nicht unbedingt veraufstiegsreif hält, dass man da versucht, noch ein bisschen Qualität reinzukriegen. Also ich glaube, man ist da auf einem ganz guten Weg.
Genau, und man hat ja dafür unter anderem auch Heia zu Verdunner Düsseldorf abgegeben.
Mit einer Abfindung, ja.
Ja, mit einer Abfindung, aber das war ja auch so eine Personalie, wo immer mehr Fragezeichen auf jeden Fall aus meiner Sicht dazu kam, der eigentlich auch mal zum absoluten Stammpersonal gehörte und dann irgendwie immer weiter auch so ein bisschen rausgeflogen ist, aus diesem auch irgendwie glaube ich so ein bisschen, da damals dann beim HSV seine Leistungen vielleicht auch nicht mal gerecht werden konnte, aus welchen Gründen auch immer und dann hat ihn dann eben abgegeben und dann haben auch Zuhun zu Regensburg. Ich finde das ganz interessant, dass man zwei Spieler abgegeben hat, dann halt bei Regensburg bei einem Respekt, nicht zu einem Ligakonkurrenten in dem Sinne, aber ja trotzdem zu...
Warte mal ab jetzt. Ich bin ja gegen Regensburg. Mal gucken.
Der trifft da. Das ist der Horror von jedem Fußballspieler.
Das ist der HSV-Fluch. Sobald irgendwo ein Ex-HSV-Spieler spielt, trifft der. Das ist Gesetz.
Ja, das steht einfach niedergeschrieben. Aber wir sagen ja auch, wir wollen Gesetze brechen, genauso wie das Frühjahrsgesetz. Vielleicht passiert das auch nicht.
Willst du eine Überleitung haben nach Versus Lautern?
Nee, nee, ich wollte nur sagen, also mein Anwalt, der weiß schon Bescheid nicht, dass es mir wieder angetrieben wird.
Aber ich meine, Ali, du wäre jetzt super als Brücke.
Ja, ganz kurz noch, wenn wir noch einmal kurz gucken, weil du gesagt hast, was sind Regensburg, da geht es jetzt auswärts. Und dann geht es gegen Kaiserslautern. Aber das ist noch nicht ganz meine Überleitung, weil dann geht es noch auswärts nach Paderborn. Also das sind die nächsten drei Spiele, sehr unterschiedliche Gegner, aber sicherlich auch spannende Aufgaben. Trotzdem wollen wir den HSV jetzt hinter uns lassen und einen Tabellenplatz weiter runter springen zum ersten FC Kaiserslautern. Es ist Platz drei, es sind 38 Punkte. Hättet ihr euch denken können, wenn ich sage sie sind punktgleich, da ist jetzt kein Punkt am Angekommen in den letzten 20 Minuten. Es sind 39 zu 31 Tore, 11 Siege, 5 Unentschieden, 5 Niederlagen. Ja und der Trainer, der ist Markus Anfang seit dieser Saison und es ist ein sehr erfolgreiches Jahr, 20, 25 bis jetzt. Sebastian, wie ist denn die Laune als FCK-Fan momentan?
Na ja, wie soll die Laune sein, wenn man mit dem FC Bayern München das einzige Team ohne Punktverlust im Jahr 2025 ist. Man muss einfach jede Chance nutzen, wenn man den Verein noch mal in einem Art und Zuge mit dem Bayern nennen kann. Nein, die Laune ist natürlich super. Also das ist ja vollkommen klar. Ich gehe mal davon aus, das wird beim HSV auch ähnlich sein. Beim FCK ist es immer so, dass die Leute halt relativ schnell sehr euphorisch werden. Also wenn ich sag mal, wenn es mal zwei, drei, vier Spiele läuft, dann guckt direkt jeder nach oben. Wenn es zwei, drei Spiele nicht so läuft, dann guckt man eher nach unten. Und dann ist so, das ist so ein geflügeltes Wort. Wir steigen auf, also wir steigen auf oder wir steigen ab. Wir steigen ab, um mal kurz ein bisschen felsisch hier reinzubringen. Also das ist schon, ja, nee. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, die Laune ist super. Aber ich glaube, die Verantwortlichen tun, also auf der einen Seite versuchen sie immer den Ball so ein bisschen flach zu halten und zu sagen, ja, und Aufstieg und ja, jetzt gucken wir mal. Und wollen natürlich oben dranbleiben. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man mal so guckt, was Vereinsboss Hengen noch so und natürlich nicht nur er allein, aber was da noch so geholt wurde in der Winterpause, könnte man schon so den Eindruck gewinnen, dass es jetzt heißt, so jetzt gehen wir all in, all or nothing. Und jetzt versuchen wir noch mal alles, weil und ich glaube, so ehrlich muss man sein, da die Liga dieses Jahr so eng ist, man weiß nicht, wie schnell noch mal eine Chance für einen Aufstieg so greifbar ist. Von daher glaube ich schon, dass man damit ein bisschen liebäugelt. Der eine oder andere sagt, es ist noch, es geht zu schnell, es ist zu früh, die Mannschaft ist nicht so weit und ja natürlich, wenn man dann so dran denkt, wie es in der Bundesliga aussieht, dann hat man schnell das Bild von der Fahrtstuhlmannschaft, finde ich im Kopf, weil auch mir so ein bisschen die Fantasie fehlt, mir vorzustellen, wie sich der FCK sollte, er jemals wieder aufsteigen kann, wie er irgendwie halten kann in der Bundesliga, aber so weit sind wir ja noch nicht. Von daher, um nochmal zur Ausgangsfrage zurückzukommen, die Stimmung ist natürlich trotz Februar Blues sehr gut.
Ja, ich musste tatsächlich nochmal nachgucken, wann Kaiserslautern zuletzt in der Bundesliga gespielt hat. Das war 2011, 2012 glaube ich. Dann hatte man ja diese vier Jahre dritte Liga dazwischen.
Unter Stefan Kunz übrigens, letzte Bundesliga-Zeit.
Warte, Stefan Kunz, Menschen, die alle das nur hören werden leider. Ja, das ist ganz toll, in Anblicks enttungen. Aber letzte Saison Platz 13 und aber ja Pokalfinale, wo am Ende Friedhelm Funkel dann da mal wieder an der Seitenlinie stand. Und davor Platz 9. Vor zehn Jahren, da war man ja auch schon mal näher dran an Liga 1, deshalb wäre das vielleicht sogar fast meine These. Also da waren es glaube ich irgendwie zwei Mann miteinander Platz 3, einmal Platz 4 oder so was in die Richtung auf jeden Fall.
Und 2013 ist man mal in der Relegation an Hoffenheim gescheitert. Das war relativ dramatisch. Das war übel damals.
Genau. Das heißt, ich verstehe eigentlich immer dieses Jahr, die Mannschaft ist noch nicht so weit und man will sich erst mal so ein bisschen in der zweiten Liga festspielen. Ich glaube, gleichzeitig hat man aber selber in der eigenen Historie auch eben das Zeichen. Na ja, du kannst dann halt immer in diesem Top 6 rumschwirren, aber du musst dann halt auch irgendwann tatsächlich aussteigen, weil Kaiserslautern hat dann ja genau den gleichen, den anderen Weg gemacht, nämlich bergab und zwar richtig, richtig bergab. Weil das ist ja auch das Problem. Also ich meine, wir hatten jetzt, du hast über Winter neu zugängengesprochen, aber es hätte natürlich auch fast einen ziemlich großen Winterabgang gegeben mit Ragnar Ache, der ja der Top-Torjäger vom vom FCK ist. Und ich glaube, wenn ich es damals richtig verstanden habe, ist er nicht gegangen, weil sein Berater unter anderem zu viel Geld haben wollte, ob das jetzt Poste ist oder wirklich so ist. Aber ja, also man konnte ihn ja glücklicherweise halten. War das denn für dich so eine Personalie, die super wichtig war, dass man die eben auch über diese Winterpause hält?
Also ja, auf jeden Fall. Ragnar Ache ist natürlich, der sticht natürlich raus. Ragnar Ache ist ein Spieler, wenn er denn fit ist, dann würde ich ihn tatsächlich auch auf einem ziemlich ähnlichen Niveau wie Glatzel sehen, auch der, wenn er dann fit ist. Also Ragnar Ache ist definitiv ein Spieler, der, wenn er sein volles Potential ausschöpft, kein Zweitligaspieler ist, sondern mindestens ein Bundesligaspieler. Das hat ja auch seinen Grund, warum der mal bei der Eintracht war, auch wenn es da noch nicht zum großen Durchbruch gereicht hat. Aber ja, seine Verletzungshistorie macht ihm doch halt immer wieder einen Strich durch die Rechnung. Man muss sagen, die vergangenen Spiele haben gezeigt, dass es auch mal funktioniert und auch die Leute treffen, wenn er nicht spielt oder auch wenn er spielt, andere die Tore machen. Von daher ist es glaube ich nochmal ein schönes Zeichen, auch dass man sieht, okay, der Kader ist gut. Es funktioniert auch, wenn Ragnar Ache keine Tore schießt, aber Ragnar Ache ist natürlich jemand, der ja alleine ein Spiel entscheiden kann. Wir haben es vorhin schon gehört, da haben wir über die Kopfballstärke von Silke gesprochen. Ragnar Ache ist auch ein Kopfballmonster, muss man wirklich so sagen, ein super krasser Kopfballspieler, super kalt schnolzig vor dem Tor. Von daher ist es natürlich so, dass es für viele auch so ein Zeichen war, okay krass, Ache bleibt. Wenn jetzt sogar der bleibt und noch die Winterzugänge dazukommen, ist der Kader eigentlich mittlerweile so gut, dass man sagen muss, ja klar spielt man nun den Aufstieg mit. Und man muss ja auch sagen, weil wir es ja gerade eben auch schon davon hatten, Aufstieg zu früh, ja gut, was will man machen? Man fängt ja jetzt deswegen nicht an und sagt, ja gut, ihr habt eigentlich recht, Aufstieg kommt zu früh, wir hören jetzt auf Tore zu schießen oder wir gewinnen jetzt keine Spiele mehr. Ist ja Quatsch. Sondern natürlich bringt die Mannschaft das auf den Rasen, was möglich ist. Natürlich wollen die jedes Spiel gewinnen. Und dann guckst du halt am Ende, wo es dann hinführt. Ich finde aber auch in diesem ganzen Kontext, erste und zweite Liga und in der ganzen Historie, die der FCK als hinter sich hat, auch mit dem Abstieg in die dritte Liga, finde ich, muss man es immer versuchen so einzuordnen. Und ich glaube, so machen sich mittlerweile selber auch, dass man sagt, man bewegt sich ungefähr zwischen, ich sag jetzt mal Platz 15 erste Liga und Platz, weiß ich nicht, 6, 7, 8 zweite Liga. Und das ist so das Niveau, auf dem man ungefähr ist und auf dem man sich quasi versucht, dauerhaft zu halten. Ich glaube, den ist auch klar, selbst wenn es dann irgendwann mal mit dem Aufstieg klappt, wird es wahrscheinlich schwer, sich zu halten in der Bundesliga. Aber ja, also warum sollten die jetzt aufhören, Punkte zu holen? Von daher, ja. Aber ja klar, wieder zur Ausgangsfrage Ratner-Ache. Schon wichtig, dass der auch noch da ist und ich schätze ihn auch persönlich so ein, dass der sich weiterhin reinhängt, auch wenn er natürlich jetzt wahrscheinlich gerne, vor allem im Anbetracht des deutschen Schmuddelwetters oder Hamburger Schiedwetters, sicherlich lieber in Italien jetzt irgendwo chillen würde und da trainieren würde. Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass der sich reinhängt, weil wenn der noch irgendwann mal weg will und er hat noch Vertrag bis 2026, dann ist jetzt die Zeit, wo er liefern muss. Weil dann muss er jetzt noch mal zeigen, was er wirklich im Köcher hat und noch mal performen. Und dann kann man gucken, wo es im Sommer dann hingeht. Und dann kann er sich überlegen, ob er dann bleibt und kann gucken, kann er vielleicht beim FCK sogar noch mal eine Runde Erste Liga spielen.
Nils, überrascht dich das ein bisschen, dass der FCK soweit um ist? Also wenn ich mich nicht verhörte, aber war der eben am Anfang bei deiner Aufzählung nicht dabei, von den ganzen Vereinen, wo du meintest, die kommen dann da immer, überrascht dich das ein bisschen, dass die da oben dabei sind.
Das war jetzt aus der Gedankenwelt des Vorsaisons, Nils. Und natürlich ist der 1. FCK laut von Namen her ein riesiger Club und von der Tradition. Aber ich hätte ihn jetzt sportlich vor der Saison nicht als Aufstiegskandidat eingeschätzt. Das ist natürlich jetzt was anderes. Jetzt würde ich den sofort aufzählen, es ist ja auch erbärmlich jemanden auf Platz 3 zu übersehen in irgendeiner Liste. Ich bin schon überrascht, dass sie jetzt so viele Punkten, ich glaube aber auch, dass ihr Rückrundenauftakt bis auf das Spiel gegen die Hertha relativ leicht war und sich natürlich Dinge dann wieder korrigieren. Also wir haben das häufig ja auch in der Saison gesehen, dass dann Mannschaften zu Beginn irgendwo stehen und dann holt sie ihr Spielplan ein oder die Form holt sie ein und dann balanciert sich das wieder so ein bisschen aus. Und da bin ich sehr gespannt, wie es dann ist, wenn Kaiserslautern auch gegen formstarke Top-Teams spielt. Also Köln, HSV, Magdeburg, Düsseldorf, Paderborn, Hannover, Elbersberg, Nürnberg, Karlsruhe, das sind ja alles Vereine, die noch kommen.
Die nächsten beiden Spiele sind Hannover und HSV, also da können wir danach noch mal reden, wie es da aussieht.
Das meine ich. Das ist halt dann jetzt noch ein bisschen Test. Also das Gute ist, glaube ich, aus Kaiserslauterner Sicht, die haben jetzt so ein Momentum und die glauben dran. Die sehen auch, oh pass mal auf, wir sind jetzt dritter, Magdeburg spielt jetzt gegen Köln. Und ja, wir haben es selber in der Hand dann auch gegen Hannover, die uns auch ein bisschen vom Leib zu halten. Lass uns mal gegen Hannover gewinnen. Lass mal mal gegen Köln jetzt gegen Magdeburg gewinnen. Oh wow, auf einmal haben wir wirklich so ein kleines Polster. Und das kann und das sieht man in der Vergangenheit oft, wenn man zurückblickt, wir können so ein Momentum erreichen. Wir können als Mannschaft sagen, ey wir glauben dann so wie das bei Kiel war zum Beispiel. Kiel war letzte Saison jetzt auch nicht Topfavorit, aber bei denen hast du irgendwann gemerkt, die haben sich als Mannschaft so sehr auf den Aufstieg zusammengeschworen. Das klappt tatsächlich und die glauben alle dran. So ein Lester-Effekt, ja. Also den englischen Verein Lester mein ich. Und das glaube ich kann Kaiserslautern erreichen. Sie haben jetzt im Winter ein bisschen zugelegt, das ist alles auf Leihbasis. Also ich glaube, wenn man aufsteigt, muss man Augsburg einladen zur Aufstiegsfeier auf jeden Fall. Ist ja auch ein Stück weit auf Punkt dann. Das ist halt das Problem, wenn du halt mit Leihspielern aufsteigst, dass du eine ohnehin schon vorhandene Qualitätslücke zu den Erstligisten dann schließen musst. Und da musst du halt schauen, dass du die möglichst hältst oder dass du dich sogar noch verbesserst. Aber nochmal, ich würde erstmal abwarten, wie Kaiserslautern gegen die Top-Teams performt, weil sonst kann es genauso gut sein, ohne jetzt Sebastian ärgern zu wollen, dass wir in ein paar Wochen, dass sich das so wieder korrigiert hat und dann sagt man ja schade, sie waren so dicht dran.
Ja, da kann ich Nils nur absolut recht geben. Also die richtigen Gradmesser, die kommen jetzt noch. Das bisher, das waren quasi jetzt mal härter ausgeklammert, das waren die Pflichtaufgaben. Und jetzt muss man mal gucken, wie es weitergeht.
Also kurz, Pflichtaufgabe gegen Ulm muss man doch erst mal gewinnen.
Ja, das wäre jetzt der nächste Satz gewesen, vor allem Respekt vor Mannschaften wie Ulm und Münster, also die auch durchaus Fußball spielen können. Aber das sind natürlich einfach andere Namen. Von daher sehe ich es genauso. Du musst jetzt einfach gucken, ob du gegen die großen Teams auch punkten kannst. Tatsächlich ist es so, dass gerade dieses Härterspiel, glaube ich, viele sehr, sehr optimistisch gestimmt hat und viele gesagt haben, okay, wenn du jetzt so ein Spiel so dreckig quasi gewinnst, dass du eigentlich das schlechtere Team bist, dann das sind die Spiele, die du gewinnen musst, wenn du aufsteigen willst. Das war wirklich so ein Paradebeispiel dafür. Von daher, und das ist auch das erste Mal, ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaube das erste Mal überhaupt gewesen, dass der FCK in der zweiten Liga gegen die Hertha gewonnen hat. Letztes Jahr zwar auch mal auswärts bei der Hertha gewonnen, das war aber Pokal. Von daher, ja, also das sind natürlich Dinge, die dann irgendwie für die Mannschaft und für das Momentum sprechen, aber man muss sehen, wie die dann auf Dauer performen auch gegen die Spitzen-Teams und auch was Nils gesagt hat. Klar, es ist natürlich alles so ein bisschen auf Pump, aber der FCK ist natürlich auch ein Verein, der sich im Moment erst mal noch nicht leisten kann, solche Spieler direkt zu verpflichten, auch so ein bisschen drauf angewiesen ist, die auf dem Radar zu haben und dann quasi kurzfristig zuzugreifen, wenn man die Chance hat, weil die halt bei ihren Bundesligaclubs keine Spielzeit kriegen. Von daher muss man es dann sehen, aber je weiter du oben stehst, das hat ja auch Thomas Hengen am letzten Wochenende gesagt, das spielt ja natürlich auch in die Karten. Du standst oben und dann kriegst du eher mal so einen Spieler, der in der ersten Liga vielleicht ein Bankdrücker ist, der nicht ganz so zum Zug kommt, der sagt dann eher mal, ja gut, guck mal, Lautern, die spielen da oben mit, da kann ich jetzt vielleicht noch mal eine schöne Rückrunde spielen und ist vielleicht gar nicht so weit weg von der Bundesliga dann entfernt. Von daher muss man dann sehen, wie sich das auch weiterentwickelt. Sollte dann irgendwann der Aufstieg folgen, ob man die Leute dann halten kann oder nicht. Aber dann hast du natürlich auch einfach finanziell noch mal ein bisschen andere Möglichkeiten als jetzt.
Bevor wir gleich noch einmal auf den Trainer zu sprechen kommen, habe ich noch eine Personalie, die du selber eben einmal angesprochen hast. Zu Beginn ist das Luca Zierch, der ist im Sommer von Lok Leipzig gekommen. Also das ist schon mal Punkt Nummer eins, außer Regionalliga in die 2. Liga ist eigentlich Abwehrspieler, aber hat jetzt eben 3 Tore und 3 Assists auch schon im Prinzip auf seinem Scoresheet gesammelt und scheint, als wäre das so mit einer der wichtigsten Spieler, die der FCK vielleicht zu letzten Sommer einfach zur Kaderergänzung dazu geholt hat. Wenn Sie mir dazu stimmen.
Definitiv. Also ich würde fast schon von einem kleinen Königstransfer sprechen oder nicht nur klein. Also diese Weitsicht auch zu haben, das war damals noch auch mit der Verdienst des mittlerweile abgewanderten Enes Hayri, der technische Direktor war, der den auch quasi auf dem Schirm hatte und ihn gesehen hat in der Regionalliga und gesagt hat, ich trau dem Jungen das zu, dass der sich auch in der 2. Liga durchsetzt. Und du hast wirklich gemerkt, der hatte ein bisschen Anlauf-Schwierigkeiten, weil ich mein, machen wir uns nichts vor, der Sprung Regionalliga, 2. Liga ist heftig. Der kam an, der war anfangs die ersten paar Spiele nicht im Kader, hat keine große Rolle gespielt. Aber je länger er dabei war, je länger er im Training mitgemacht hat, sich an das Tempo, die Härte und so weiter gewöhnt hat, desto mehr hast du gemerkt, okay, der Junge kommt jetzt langsam an. Und mittlerweile guckst du dir an, was der auf dem Platz abliefert. Und das sieht eigentlich so aus, als hätte der nie was anderes gemacht. Also das ist wirklich so ein kleines Märchen. Und glücklicherweise haben die Verantwortlichen das auch relativ schnell erkannt, dass sich das so in die Richtung entwickeln wird und haben dann rechtzeitig auch den Vertrag nochmal verlängert. Von daher, klar, muss man auch sehen, das ist jetzt quasi die erste Zweitliga-Saison. Und jetzt erst so richtig durchgestartet kann er das Niveau dann auch halten. Aber auf jeden Fall ein absoluter Glücksgriff.
Ja, ich liebe so Geschichten. Also beim HSV hab ich ja von Daniel Elfattli erwähnt, bei dem ist es ähnlich. Auch der musste sich da aus unterklassigen Liegen hochkämpfen. Und das ist immer so, ich meine, Keils Laudern kennt das ja auch mit Miroclose. Das war ja auch damals so eine Geschichte, der eben nicht diese Leistungszentren durchlaufen hat. Und wenn dann auf einmal so jemand kommt und eigentlich die karierischen Adapter gelegt hat und spielt einen Profifußball, ich find das so geile Geschichten, kann ich mich total mit identifizieren. Weil bei Lok Leipzig, der Regionalliga, ist ja auch eine dieser blöden Ligen, wo du eigentlich vom Zeitaufwand Profifußballer bist, aber vom Gehalt her keine Rücklagen hast für nach der Karriere sozusagen. Deswegen ist das einfach eine super Geschichte.
Und du hast beim FCK eigentlich noch eine zweite ähnliche Geschichte. Du hast Leon Robinson noch, der vergangenes Jahr noch zur Oberliga-Mannschaft gehört hat, da auch Kapitän war. Oder falls er da jetzt in der Saison wird es nicht mehr so sein, aber wenn er ab und zu mal noch da gespielt hat, auch wieder Kapitän direkt war, der auch nie ein NLZ gesehen hat und der aber auch sich quasi durch gute Leistungen in der zweiten Mannschaft für die Profis dann empfohlen hat. Auch wenn der vielleicht, ja, ich weiß nicht inwiefern er sich wirklich eine Chance ausgerechnet hat, aber das sind wirklich einfach geile Geschichten. Natürlich ist es super, dass die Jungs heutzutage die NLZs durchlaufen, dass die Bedingungen da professionell sind und so weiter. Alles schön und gut, aber es ist schon irgendwie auch cool und es freut mich, wenn so Jungs dann den Durchbruch schaffen. Und dann muss ich auch sagen, wir haben bei uns im Podcast, es ist so, dass quasi eigentlich immer entweder ein Spieler oder ein Verantwortlicher auch dann zu Gast ist. Und die waren auch beide schon da und haben uns lang mit denen unterhalten. Und das sind so Jungs, wo du merkst, die sind total bodenständig. Das sind einfach, die kicken einfach, weil die Bock haben zu kicken und die machen sich keine großen Gedanken und sind halt klar, da muss man jetzt auch abwarten, wie sich das weiterentwickelt. Aber die haben zumindest, so wie ich das einschätze, relativ wenig Potenzial abzuheben, sondern sind ziemlich bodenständige Jungs. Von daher ist das einfach ein absoluter Glücksfall.
Ja, da bin ich auch, ich fand den Kader von Kaiserslautern auch spannend, weil ich irgendwie so dachte, ja was hat sich denn da so viel getan? Und ich fand irgendwie auch spannend, dass man irgendwie ein bisschen vergisst, dass man unter anderem ja auch Tomiak abgegeben hat an Hannover, wenn ich das jetzt nicht falsch... Aber so, man erstmal, also erstmal dachte so, das könnte jetzt irgendwie ja doch irgendwie nochmal entscheidend sein, einfach weil das jetzt schon irgendwie so ein Name ist, den man irgendwie immer kannte. Also es ist ja durchaus ein erfahrener Spieler auch irgendwie, aber mehr hat man bisher auf jeden Fall wenig von. Aber lass uns doch jetzt tatsächlich einmal auf den Trainer schauen, beziehungsweise willst du erst noch was anderes sagen, bevor ich dich...
Nee, ich wollte eigentlich nur sagen, dass es bei Boris Tomiak ähnlich war wie bei Sirch. Defensiver Spieler, aber auch mit ordentlich Zug zum Tor, der hat zum Beispiel auch die Elfmeter immer geschossen beim FCK. Und von daher war man da schon am Anfang so, okay krass, wenn der jetzt geht, ob der eine große Lücke hinterlässt, aber es denkt jetzt keiner mehr an Boris Tomiak, bei allem Respekt vor Boris Tomiak, der ein super Kicker ist, aber die Lücke, die da entstanden ist, hat man nie wirklich gesehen auf dem Platz.
Ja, aber dann lass uns einmal tatsächlich auf Markus Anfang blicken. Also er hat ja im Sommer übernommen, nachdem man ja, man hat ja ganz kurz Recap, letzte Saison ist Dirk Schuster als Trainer, hat ihn dann entlassen, hat dann mit Friedhelm Funkel zu Ende gemacht. Und jetzt eben Markus Anfang. Wie, also ich glaube so ganz einfach, weil die Personalie Markus Anfang ja immer so ein bisschen diskutiert ist sowieso, dann kam er ja von der Zeit bei Dynamo Dresden, wo er ja zweimal hintereinander den Ausstieg verpasst hat von der dritten, von der dritten in die zweite Liga. Was war denn eigentlich dein erster Gedanke damals, als es dann hieß Markus Anfang, der wird's jetzt?
Tatsächlich war der erste Gedanke, puh könnte schwierig werden. Aber so ging es einfach vielen, weil man sagen muss, dass natürlich die Personalien Markus Anfang in diesem Fußball-Zirkus, ja natürlich einfach so durch diese Impfpass-Geschichte sehr negativ behaftet war, teilweise auch immer noch ist. Und natürlich hatte ich, wie viele andere auch, einfach ziemlich große Vorbehalte, ob das funktionieren kann. Weil ich das immer auch schwierig finde, jetzt ganz unabhängig davon, warum dieser Mensch so im Fokus steht, wenn dieser Fokus so sehr auf dieser Person ist. Egal ob jetzt im positiven oder negativen Sinne, natürlich brauchst du, und natürlich ist es immer so, wenn du große Trainernamen hast, die polarisieren. Ist ja vollkommen klar. Aber gerade bei einem Club wie Lautern ist es dann so, wenn dann so jemand kommt. Ja, also da gab es einfach super viele Vorbehalte, ob das funktionieren kann. Aber ich glaube, Markus Anfang hat es mittlerweile oder nicht, ich glaube, sondern es ist Fakt. Man sieht es, man merkt es im Umfeld, hat es geschafft, die Leute von seiner Arbeit zu überzeugen, hat es geschafft, der Mannschaft seine eigene Handschrift zu geben. Und ja, was soll man sagen? Der Erfolg gibt ihm natürlich recht. Also es ist ja bei vielen Leuten, mir geht es ja ähnlich wie Nils. Hättest du mich vor der Saison gefragt, hätte ich auch nicht gesagt, dass ich davon ausgehe, dass der FCK eine Rolle im oberen Drittel spielt. Oder im oberen Drittel vielleicht schon, aber dass der FCK ein Wörtchen um die Aufstiegspätze mitredet, hätte ich niemals gedacht. Klar, wir haben es gerade eben schon gesagt, wir müssen abwarten, wie es sich entwickelt, ob sie sich dauerhaft da oben festsetzen können. Aber der Erfolg gibt ihm recht und mittlerweile weiß ich nicht, wie lange ich jetzt schon nichts mehr negatives in Sachen Markus Anfang gehört habe.
Kann ich was zu sagen?
Natürlich.
Ja, weil ich habe ein ziemlich teures Szenario, weil Markus Anfang ist verantwortlich dafür, dass Werder Bremen damals aufgestiegen ist und nicht der HSV, weil das dann mit dem Trainerwechsel auf Werner bei Werder wieder bergauf ging. Und wenn ihr jetzt mit Anfang aufsteigt und der HSV dann vielleicht nur dritter wird oder so, dann ist er für den zweiten nicht aufstiegsverantwortlich.
Ja, das haben wir auch extra, das haben die Verantwortlichen extra so geplant. Das ist der Plan, wie man den HSV hinter sich lässt.
Das ist mein Gefühl, dass da was dran ist.
Aber man muss ja dazu sagen, also ich finde halt so interessant, weil jetzt mal abgesehen von der Personalien Markus Anfang im öffentlichen Sinne, Markus Anfang auf sportlicher Ebene, also er kommt halt dahingehend aus diesen zwei Dresden-Jahren natürlich auch nicht ganz unbelastet raus. Von daher, also und ich meine auch da war, also wir sprechen nicht von Dynamo, ist kachend am Aufstieg gescheitert, sondern Dynamo Dresden war gefühlt bis fünf Tage vor Schluss im Aufstiegsrennen dabei und ist dann gescheitert. Sie haben quasi den HSV gepole, nur in der dritten Liga. Entschuldige, da ist nichts. Bin gewohnt. Also deshalb war es für mich tatsächlich eine überraschende Personalien, weil ich gedacht habe, naja, er kommt jetzt einfach nicht mit der besten Vita, einfach von seinen Nicht-Erfolgen zuletzt. Und das war bei mir so im Hintergrund.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber da muss ich schon auch sagen, natürlich hat es dann bei Dresden knapp nicht gereicht, aber streckenweise oder über lange Strecken hat es ja ganz gut funktioniert und hat die Mannschaft auch ganz gut performt in Dresden unter Markus Anfang. Von daher, aber die Frage ist ja auch immer, und das auch jetzt bei allem Respekt vor Markus Anfang, vor seinem Namen, vor seiner Arbeit, aber was hat man denn für Ansprüche in Kaiserslautern, wen man auch im Hinblick darauf, wie es in den vergangenen Jahren gelaufen ist, wem man da als Trainer präsentieren kann. Da war es auch so, das war nicht nur, dass die Leute gesagt haben, oh Mensch, Markus Anfang, heißes Eisen mit seiner Geschichte da, aber da war es auch so, Markus Anfang, wir brauchen doch hier, wir brauchen einen anderen Namen, wir brauchen jemanden mit mehr Standing und kann noch nicht sein, aber ja. Also da muss man sich, das ist das, was ich auch, das sage ich bei uns im Podcast ganz oft, das sage ich hier jetzt auch, das sage ich in meinem privaten Umfeld ganz oft. Man muss diesen berühmten Schritt zurück ganz oft mal machen und mal gucken, wo kommen wir denn überhaupt her? Natürlich ist der FCK, wie es Nils auch schon gesagt hat, ein großer Name, viel Tradition und so weiter und so fort. Davon kannst du dir aber nichts kaufen. Du kannst dir nichts davon kaufen, dass du 98 als Aufsteiger deutscher Meister warst. Du kannst dir jetzt auch nicht viel davon kaufen, dass du vergangenes Jahr im Pokalfinale warst, auch wenn das super, super wichtig war, auch für den Zusammenhalt mit den Fans und für die ganze Euphorie, die da jetzt insgesamt entstanden ist. Aber man muss sich bewusst machen, wo kommt der FCK her? Der FCK kommt aus super bitteren Drittliga-Jahren. Der FCK wäre fast von der Bildfläche erst mal für längere Zeit verschwunden. Also auch finanziell. Viel ist einfach schlecht gelaufen in den vergangenen Jahren. Also wer ist der FCK oder wer sind die Leute, dass sie sagen, wir hätten jetzt hier, was weiß ich, hätten wir nicht mal bei Pep Guardiola oder so anfangen, wenn ich jetzt übertrieben gesagt hätte. Aber von daher, klar hat es vielleicht viele gewundert, aber ich glaube, mittlerweile sieht man, dass es relativ gut matcht. Jetzt muss man sehen, wie nachhaltig ist das Ganze. Es wäre generell auch mal schön, wenn beim FCK mal wieder ein Trainer für längere Zeit einfach die Chance hätte, was zu entwickeln, weil davon redet man beim FCK auch schon seit Jahren. Man redet davon, es muss nachhaltig was entwickelt werden. Und was mich da auch immer so ein bisschen fuchst, ist diese Tatsache, wenn du davon sprichst, was zu entwickeln, dann musst du ja eigentlich als Verein, als Vereinsführung eine gewisse Spielidee haben und sagen, ich richte mich danach aus, das gebe ich vor und dementsprechend holen wir Personal, holen wir Trainer, die so spielen. Wenn du aber mal guckst, wen du in den vergangenen Jahren beim FCK als Trainer hattest von Marco Antwerpen über Friedhelm Funkel, über Demetrius Gramozis, jetzt Marco Antwerpen, das sind ja völlig unterschiedliche Trainertypen. Von daher wäre es jetzt auch mal an der Zeit und eigentlich ganz nett, wenn mal jemand über längere Zeit die Chance bekommt, da was zu entwickeln, weil ich glaube einfach dieser Verein, diese Region, das wird ja auch immer sehr, sehr häufig zitiert und auch kritisiert, dass da von der Region gesprochen wird. Aber das hat so viel Potenzial und da musst du jetzt mal jemandem die Chance geben, das über längere Zeit wieder zu wecken und aufzubauen. Von daher, ja, also ich glaube, it's a match mit Markus Anfang.
Wie siehst du das dann finanziell? Also wie sagst du denn, braucht der FCK auch mal wieder ein Bundesliga-Jahr aus finanziellen Gründen oder sagst du okay, wenn du jetzt irgendwie in diesen einfach diese Drittliga-Jahre erstmal hinter dir lässt, in dieser Fünf-Jahres-Wertung eben einfach auch das rein finanziell zwei, drei Jahre, zweite Liga auch vollkommen in Ordnung wären?
Der FCK braucht definitiv wieder mehr Einnahmen. Dem FCK würde es vor allem gut tun, sich jetzt mal unabhängig vom Aufstieg, sich über längere Zeit auch mal in einem hohen einstelligen Tabellenplatz, auch in der zweiten Liga einfach zu etablieren, dass du in der TV-Geld-Tabelle einfach kontinuierlich weiter nach oben kommst, weil da merkst du einfach, dass immer wieder bei dem Thema, wo kommst du her aus Drittliga-Zeiten? Es dauert einfach super lange und du musst super lange wieder relativ erfolgreich sein, bis du auf einem einigermaßen vernünftigen Level bist, weil du hinkst einfach den Mannschaften, die in der Zeit, wo du dritte Liga gespielt hast, zweite Liga gespielt haben, du hinkst denen super hinterher. Von der Bundesliga muss man gar nicht sprechen. Thomas Hengen hat da auch als Beispiel Heidenheim angeführt, die einfach über super lange Zeit kontinuierlich in der zweiten Liga einen guten Job gemacht haben, relativ weit oben mitgespielt haben, dadurch hohe Einnahmen generiert haben durch die TV-Gelder und mittlerweile dann den Sprung nach oben geschafft haben. Von daher ja, der FCK braucht das definitiv, dass das einfach wieder ein bisschen mehr möglich ist. Was natürlich super geholfen hat, war natürlich der Pokal. Also diese Pokalsaison, das sind natürlich die besten Einnahmen, die du haben kannst, Einnahmen, mit denen du nicht rechnest, die du nicht einkalkuliert hast und die dann quasi überraschend kommen. Plus natürlich alles das, was damit einhergeht, dass du einfach wieder so ein kleines Ausrufezeichen auf der Landkarte gesetzt hast und gesagt hast, hey, hallo, wir sind immer noch da, uns gibt es immer noch, hi FCK, wir waren lange nicht da, jetzt sind wir wieder da. Yes, you're back. Genau.
Ja, also ich bin jetzt wirklich sehr gespannt, was zumindest nach den nächsten zwei, aber vielleicht auch sogar nach den nächsten drei Spielen passiert, weil du hast eben jetzt Hannover HSV als die nächsten beiden Gegner zu Hause gegen Hannover aus jetzt beim HSV. Und dann hast du zu Hause noch mal gegen Regensburg. Also eigentlich dann noch mal so ein Gegner, der rein vom Tabellenplatz eigentlich in die diese Gegner rund um Münster und Ulm einpasst. Von daher wird das da natürlich auch spannend sein, wie kriegst du da wieder den Switch in? Also zwischen diesen Hoch- und Runterspielen quasi.
Das war in der Hinrunde eins der miesesten Spiele, ein 0 zu 0 in Regensburg. Also das sind unangenehme Gegner, auch wenn die jetzt natürlich irgendwie abgeschlagen da unten am Tabellenende stehen. Aber die musst du auch erstmal schlagen. Und ich glaube, da hatte HSV in der Vergangenheit auch so ein paar Erlebnisse mit solchen Teams gemacht.
Also was du schon gesagt hast, das waren nicht nur Aufsteiger. Es waren beim HSV sogar, wenn das Stadion weniger als 20.000 Leute fasst, hat der HSV glaube ich noch nie in der zweiten Liga gewonnen.
Krank. So Elbersberg und sowas.
Ja, also das ist genau diese Atmosphäre, die ist ja überall gleich eng, meistens schlechter Rasen. Es wird gekämpft, es wird gerackert, es gibt Standardsituationen und so. Und so einen Gegner zu bespielen, erfordert auch ein ganz anderes Mindset, eine ganz andere taktische Herangehensweise als jetzt ein Duell gegen die Großen. Und du hast halt natürlich in dieser Liga sehr viele Vereine, die Ambition haben, weshalb sie gegen eine Mannschaft wie Kaiserslautern auch mitspielen und sagen, ich will das Spiel gewinnen. Das ist halt was anderes, als wenn du Geregensburg, Münster, Ulm, Braunschweig bespielst, die vielleicht sagen, ne macht ihr mal und dann ist Kaiserslautern eben auch als Spitzenteam dann gefordert, Lösungen zu finden gegen solche Mannschaften.
Aber hat der Asphal nicht schon mal gegen Paraborn gewonnen? In Paraborn? Sicherlich.
Also die Statistik habe ich nur gelesen und nicht selber recherchiert. Von daher kann es natürlich auch absoluter Quatsch sein. Aber jetzt ist es draußen in der Welt, andere Leute werden es reproduzieren und irgendwann wird es zur Wahrheit.
Ne, aber ich könnte es tatsächlich so auch nicht sagen. Ich habe auch vielleicht auch einfach so Gedächtnis, Evidenz. Aber ich bin tatsächlich sehr gespannt, was da eben auch rauskommt bei beiden Vereinen, ehrlich gesagt. Also eben beim HSV und bei Kaiserslautern. Ich sage es ganz ehrlich, ich würde es vor allem dem HSV jetzt auch einfach mal gönnen. Erstens, ich habe auch einfach keine Lust mehr auf diese Witze. Es ist einfach sämtliche Medienabteilungen lachen sich jedes Jahr im Frühjahr irgendwie ein ab und ich finde es einfach nur noch nervig.
Von daher können wir sagen, das ist Mobbing, das ist so ein Bulliverhalten. Na ist doch so, wir kennen alle so Leute in der Schule, das ist wenn das Opfer eh schon im Spind eingesperrt wird, dann kommen die Witze raus. Und das ist Bulli, ich notiere mir das, ich höre ganz kurz an die lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen, ich notiere mir das seit Jahren. Ich weiß genau, wer hier welche Sprüche bringt und irgendwann kommt Redemption Day.
Ja, also als Fan und ja, nicht nur Fan, sondern auch Bewohnerin der Stadt Bielefeld, ja, weiß ich alles zu Witzen und dass man sie einfach nicht mehr hören kann.
Aber wo wohnst du wirklich, weil Bielefeld gibt es ja nicht.
Genau, also es kann auch wirklich, ich glaube, ihr könnt ihr einfach mal eine Bombe hochgehen und der erste Kommentar bei Instagram, mir hör mal Bielefeld gibt es doch gar nicht. Von daher, ich fühle das sehr. Vielleicht habe ich deshalb auch ein bisschen Mitleid, weil man es einfach nicht mehr hören kann. Aber ich würde sagen, wir sind am Ende dieser Folge angelangt. Ich hätte mit euch beiden 100 prozentig schon eine Stunde mehr reden können, weil es eigentlich nur so viele Themen gibt, die wir jetzt nicht abgearbeitet haben. Aber ihr müsst ja einfach nochmal wiederkommen. So einfach ist das. Ein bisschen dauert die Saison ja noch. Deshalb danke ich als allererstes Nils Bommer für seine Premiere im Rasenfunk, dass du dich erfolgreich eingeklagt hast.
Ja, danke nochmal an meinen Anwalt und herzlichen Dank fürs Einknicken und die Einladung.
Und vielen Dank auch an Sebastian. Schön, dass du auch hier, muss man ja auch sagen, eingesprungen bist quasi durch diverse andere Gegebenheiten hier. Also Sebastian, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du mal wieder was zum FCK erzählt hast.
Ich finde es super, dass du nochmal deutlich gemacht hast den Leuten, dass ich eigentlich nur die zweite oder dritte Wahl war, aber es ist überhaupt kein Problem. Ich komme auch als zweite oder dritte Wahl immer sehr gerne, gar kein Thema.
Sie ist wie Polzin.
Ja, sie ist wie Polzin.
Oder wie der FCK im Ausstiegsrennen.
Und nächste Woche bin ich in Hamburg vor Ort beim Spiel gegen den HSV, von daher Nils, ich würde dem HSV auf jeden Fall auch irgendwann den Aufstieg gönnen. Habe ich sehr große Sympathie für diese Stadt auch, weil ich da selber auch mal eine Zeit lang gewohnt hab. Von daher, ja, aber an diesen Spieltag.
Da nicht gerade da aufsteigen.
Nee.
Ich glaube, das wird auch schwierig. Ich bedanke mich auch bei allen Zuhörenden. Es geht dann nächste Woche. Hoffentlich. Vielleicht sollte er einfach solche Prognosen lassen. Hoffentlich nächste Woche hier tatsächlich schon wieder mit Marc weiter. Freut euch drauf und freut euch auf ein Wochenende. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.